mzc real quickly he is not Jesus if
that's what you're asking
me mzc is not an appearance of Jesus in
the Old Testament is that what you're
asking me slave for gold for God I'll
give you an article I wrot on it
but I'll give you proof of it real
quickly is that what you're asking me is
MZ okay Hebrews 7 verse3 and verse1 15
Hebrews 7 verse3 and verse
15 s went to Iraq he's visiting Iraq
because this guy's got no question all
right slave listen to this Hebrews 73
and5 without father without mother
without genealogy having neither
beginning of days nor end of life but
made like the Son of God remains a
priest continually and now speaking of
Jesus and it is yet far more evident if
in the likeness of mzc there arises
another priest so it says MDC is made
like Jesus and Jesus is like MDC if
you're like someone you're not that
someone
mzc was made like Jesus and Jesus is in
the likeness of mzc if you're like
someone you're not that
someone because Abraham knew that he's a
priest of God and the
priest had the right to your tithe just
like the levitical priest received the
tithe from Israel what kind of question
is that Abraham knew that this was a
priest of God honored by God exalted by
God and served God and wanted his
blessing all right so slave did you get
your
answer did you get your answer slave
okay now let me explain why it says
without father and
mother without beginning of days or end
of life without genology okay let me
explain that are you ready and I'm going
to give you the article before I end the
session I have an article on this why
does Hebrew say mzc has no father and
mother no beginning of days no end of
life no genealogy okay why is he saying
that okay what Hebrews is telling you is
God inspired the author of Genesis Moses
to depict mzc in such a way as to give
you the impression mzc has no parents
wasn't born wasn't and didn't die why
because mzc appears out of nowhere we're
not told his who his parents are we're
not told that he was born we're not told
that he died and was replaced he appears
out of nowhere and he's so great Abraham
recognizes his greatness that this man
is truly a priest of God anointed by God
and I need to be blessed of him so why
were those details omitted because God
was inspiring Moses to describe mzc in
such a way to give you the impression
that MDC was an eternal person
not because he was but because he was
designed to be a picture of the reality
remember what I've been telling you guys
all the Old Testament is a shadow of the
reality the reality is Jesus the Old
Testament is a shadow see when you see a
shadow you know someone's coming if you
look at a shadow and you see a shadow
that looks like a dog you know a dog is
coming if you see a shadow that looks
like a cat you know a cat is coming if
you see a shadow looks human you know a
human being is coming so what Hebrews is
saying is God designed the Old Testament
to be a shadow so you know who's coming
so malesic is designed in such a way to
appear as an eternal person uncreated
and deathless guess what folks that
means the person that he's pointing to
he is eternal he is deathless he is
uncreated mzc is a shadow not the
reality the reality is Jesus so mzc was
designed to be Eternal not because he
was because he's a shadow of the one who
is eternal and a priest
forever you get it
now everything went smooth but I'm not
still completely free Duncan keep
praying for my Miracle is it making
sense
now Enoch is simply taking Daniel 7 and
running with it and bringing out the
theological import implications of
Daniel 7 which Jesus fulfills perfectly
okay I want everyone to get this point
now now let me tell you how
amazingly an amazing picture mzc is of
Jesus Hebrews 713 tells you mezer means
my king is righteous or the king of
righteousness M zadik zad that means
king of righteousness and king of Sal
Salem shim which later became Jerusalem
shalam is the same word where we get
Shalom Peace So notice this one is the
king of righteousness the king of Peace
lo and behold Jesus is the prince of
peace and he is righteous and the king
of righteousness it's number one number
two when MDC meets Abraham and his
318 men he brings Bread and Wine and
eats with them Bread and Wine what did
Jesus do broke bread and gave wine as
the Eucharist celebrating his death for
our sins do you think that's a
coincidence do you think that's a
coincidence Genesis 1418 to 20 MZ
meaning king of righteousness king of
Salem me meit sham king of peace
Bread and Wine Jesus king of kings Lord
of lords king of Peace Prince of Peace
king of righteousness the righteous one
of God and he gives Bread and
Wine and he's a priest wow so you see
what Hebrews is saying mzc is not
Eternal but he's depicted in such a way
to point to the one who is eternal by
Nature who is uncreated by nature who
became flesh to die as a sacrifice for
our sins and now abides as a priest
forever who truly is the king of
righteousness the king of Peace who gave
Bread and Wine to his servants